So remember at the beginning of this unit when I introduced you
to nondeterminism and the "if-better" function?
And we also talked about simulating the if-better function
and how this takes exponential time to do?
And I imagine your first reaction to this might have been
a mild version of "So what?" or even "This is ridiculous."
But now, think what this means in the context of NP-completeness.
If, for any NP-complete problem, you find a deterministic algorithm
that runs in polynomial time, then you have also found a way to simulate
a nondeterministic RAM in polynomial time,
which would mean that a normal, deterministic RAM without the if-better function
is just as powerful as one that has this function.
Which, of course, seems a bit strange because our intuition, of course, tells us
that having this if-better function is super, super powerful
and should somehow make a difference.
So the cool thing is, there's only 2 possibilities.
Either all NP-complete problems can be solved in polynomial time,
which would essentially mean that P=NP.
So any problem that can be solved in polynomial time on a nondeterministic RAM
can be solved in polynomial time on a deterministic RAM.
Or, in other words, a deterministic RAM is just as powerful as a nondeterministic one.
Or it could be the other case, and that is no NP-complete problem
can be solved in polynomial time.
So P≠NP.
There are certain problems that you can solve in polynomial time
if you have the if-better function available, but you can not solve them
in polynomial time if you don't have this function.
So basically, you'd say P≠NP is the same as saying that
the if-better function is really powerful.
So which one is it? And that question is the famous P vs NP problem.
Because the thing is, we don't know. Nobody knows.
Asking this question here, if P=NP or P≠NP, is a problem that is decades old,
and yet nobody has been able to figure it out.
Now, given how powerful this if-better function is, remember when I introduced it to you?
It seemed like this magic function that could solve all of our problems.
Many computer scientists nowaday believe that P≠NP,
but nobody has been able to prove it.
On the other hand, also nobody has been able to find
a polynomial time algorithm for any single NP-complete problem,
despite, literally, thousands of practically-relevant NP-complete problems being out there.
Now let's think a little bit of how you could resolve this question.
So how could you show that P=NP or P≠NP? And we'll do that as a quiz.
So I'm going to give you a number of accomplishments or things that you could do,
and I would like you to tell me what that would show.
So, for example, if you found a polynomial-time algorithm for an NP-complete problem,
would that show that P=NP, would that show that P≠NP,
or would that show nothing interesting?
And what if you found an algorithm that solves an NP-complete problem
in polynomial time on average?
So not worst-case running time, but average-case running time.
And what about if you showed that the most efficient algorithm for clique
requires exponential time, on the deterministic RAM, of course?
Would that show that P=NP, P≠NP, or something else, or we don't know?
What if you showed that the vertex cover problem has an exponential number
of potential solutions that any algorithm has to go through?
What if you were able to reduce the clique problem to the shortest path problem?
So shortest path is finding the shortest path between 2 vertices in a graph.
What if you were to reduce clique to the problem of finding the shortest path
between 2 vertices in a graph?
Or what if you could show that any shortest path problem in a graph
can be solved by solving clique in a transformed graph?
So please make your selection. Which ones are correct?